hello my name is Forrest Zhang and today
I'll be discussing research done with
Professor Greg Bodwin at the University
of Michigan on rating systems with a
potential compatible property that we
call opponent indifference
we'll start off by discussing what
exactly our rating system is our rating
system is a set of functions used to
give and adjust real number of ratings
um associated with players in
competitive games
these ratings are used to rank players
with higher rate ratings being better
and to predict the outcome of matching
results
our model specifically considers ratings
that are one one-dimensional meaning
that they only consider one rating
parameter two memory realists which
means that they don't consider any other
rating statistics for example maybe uh
win loss percentage and three zero sum
meaning that they only that that rating
gained by one player corresponds to
rating loss by another player
um these these uh specifications of our
model are tweaks and generalizations of
previous rating systems discussed in the
resources below
foreign
ly speaking we say a rating system must
have a skill curve
which gives the probability of winning
for a player with a rating of the first
input against the player overrating of
the second input
and an adjustment function which gives
the amount of running gained from a
match by a player with a rating of the
first input if they beat a player with a
rating of the second input
we also require that
um
now the skill code would be draw free
which means that it just there is no
possibility draws
um
a lot of rating systems have this like
ELO and they account for draws by
um basically saying it's a half win and
a half a loss and
that's a pretty easy way to account for
it mathematically
and just and this is just done to make
things easier to
for for the model it's simpler
and we also require the higher ratings
have a higher chance of winning so that
means that
um it must the the skill code must be
increasing in the first input and
decreasing in the second input
our adjustment function must also be
consequential which means it's possible
for someone to gain rating from the
match
um
and this is natural because then matches
are actually meaningful in terms of
rating also their matches that don't
actually do anything
um additionally we cannot just have an
arbitrary skill curve and an adjustment
function we have to have a fairness
Axiom I'm going to State this in terms
of a expected gain function
um and for this function we follow the
model that every single player has a
current and true rating
um that a lot of other previous Works
follow
um
where the current rating uh is what the
rating system thinks your rating should
be and it's what has it in log and the
true meaning is what actually is the
probability of you winning a match so
and then the true ratings denoted by the
star
um so our expected gain function then
has four inputs the first two inputs
being associated with the first player
and the second two inputs being
associated with the second player
um and we have the
the probability of winning times of
waiting gain if you win red if you win
subtracted by the probability of losing
times the rating loss
um if you lose and this essentially just
the expected value of the rating change
um and then the fairness Axiom is
stating that if both players are
correctly rated the expected gauge
should be zero
um
discussing prior work um you'll see that
ELO is the most popular rating system to
the point that ratings are sometimes
just called yellow
and it's based on the logistics skill
curve
um where you have
which is Stone on the right where like a
rating system of a rating difference of
like minus 100 would be associated with
a
um wind percentage of 40 in this case
and um most previous Works focuses on
adding additional parameters to increase
accuracy of match predictions uh for
example we have glucose which is a
two-dimensional lift of Elo that also
incorporates a volatility parameter
um and this will make it so that your
rating increases uh rating changes
higher if your volatility parameters
higher
because this has been shown to converge
to uh true ratings faster
um but we actually focus more on
something called the sense of
compatibility where
um you want the rating system designed
to encourage behavior that is compatible
with what the rating systems designers
want the players to to do so a recent
line of work actually looks at glico and
sees if we can exploit it and asks
um exploit this volatility parameter and
ask whether or not glico is incentive
compatible
um and it turns out that it is not
incentive compatible because of
volatility hacking so
um this is when a player lowers their
rating to a point where they can control
the outcome of a match
um here games are easy enough so that
they can win if they wanted to and they
can alternate between winning and losing
sets of games to form to farm volatility
um and with this higher volatility they
can then play normally and overshoot the
the rating in which they would naturally
converge to pretty consistently
um this is bad for a sense of
compatibility for uh two reasons
for one
players don't want to win every game but
also
um there are there are behaviors that
are not associated with how good you are
at the game that affect your rating and
can affect it pretty consistently
um which means that the ratings do not
accurately reflect the skill of the
players
and this exploit was first discovered in
Pokemon go actually and it had practical
implications
um for the leaderboard where
um it was much easier to get higher
places on the leaderboard if you use
this exploit
um
that's currently you actually showed the
other rating systems are also vulnerable
to a similar attack
um and the proposed ways to to fix this
in a recent paper
our motivations are a little bit
different we focus on a less pernicious
but perhaps more common type of attack
called opponent selection where players
will choose opponents with specific
ratings to maintain a higher average
rating than if they that otherwise
um we've always shown that if you're
correctly rated and your opponent's
correctly rated that this um
there's no benefit to choosing opponents
of specific ratings but this becomes
more of a concern if you're incorrectly
rated and a lot of times you aren't
correctly rated your rating will your
tributing will fluctuate a lot
um from day to day if and over time
um so for example you might be tired in
one day and in that case you actually
know that if you're tired that you're
probably overrated that day so maybe
that day you you choose opponents of a
specific rating of over other opponents
and this is a concern mainly for chess
websites where they give you a lot of
control over your opponent's ratings
Um this can be done in three ways one is
a boarding games after seeing the rating
of your opponents without any rating
penalty
um two is limiting the rating of
matchmaking so that you only play
players within a specific rating range
and three is selectively initiating
matches against specific players or
accepting challenges of players of
specific uh ratings and this is the
ultimate these things can be done on the
two most popular uh chess websites
chess.com and Lee chess
and this is not incentive compatible for
the same reason as Clicquot where you
have things other than skill affecting
the ratings
and we focus on designing a rating
systems that structurally defend against
this type of attack
um and we call these ratings opponents
indifferent
to informally describe what we want we
want a rating system that
does not give any rating incentive to
selectively choose your opponent
um before discussing exactly
more results there are some useful
Notions and ideas of uh about writing
systems to discuss
um one is the K function which is a
generalization of an idea from ELO where
they describe their their adjustment
functions in terms of the skill curve
and a k Factor
um
we generalize this to say that it's a to
say that it's a function it's not a
factor so this could be the non-constant
and we say it's equal to
um Alpha of X Y plus Alpha of y x and we
get this result from manipulating the
expected gain function
and the fairness Axiom
we also have this idea of triviality on
trivial rating systems are basically
flat all readings mean the same thing
practically speaking and these rating
systems are not very useful and they
create weird edge cases so many of the
results will just omit them and we have
this idea of translation in variance
which means that skill curve is
completely determined by differences in
rating
um so
probability that up percent rating 100
beating a rating of 90 would be the same
as a probability of a person written 10
beating a player of of ready to zero
and I said before
um ELO is is
um is translation variant and this is a
plus because translation translation in
variant skill curves are a lot easier to
interpret
um basically across the board it means
rating changes and ring differences mean
the same thing
um moving on we have a first attempt at
defending against uh opponent selection
attacks we call this opponent
indifference formerly we say that the
expected gain function when your
opponent is correctly rated only depends
on your true rating and current rating
um and we find that we actually do have
opponent in different rating systems and
they have some structure
um you find two things one is that they
must have a constant K function and two
they must be written in this form in
terms of a of a single input function we
call a bisector that's a weekly
increasing
um
and we call when the skill curve is in
this form what we call it's separatable
um all this sounds really good uh it
sounds like we're maybe even done that
we've solved the problem but um turns
out that these uh opponent in different
rating systems aren't very useful and
mainly it's because of their ability to
measure the depth of a player pool
so for array system to be useful there
has to be some notion of depth in the
player pool
um and we kind of want a way to gauge if
a player if a rating system is able to
to be useful in any way at measuring
depth
um and we can we can use this idea of
skill chains to help us out with that so
a skill chain is basically when you have
a list of uh
of ratings such that the a player with
the first rating beats the play with the
second rating with higher probability
like the second reading beats the next
player um with another with also
similarly high probability and so on uh
for example for example
um
in chess you have a grand master being a
tournament player with 95 probability a
tournament player being a hobbyist with
95 probability and a hobbyist being a
beating a beginner with 95 probability
um so this would be a skill chain of
length four
and
and trying to gauge if a rating system
can be useful in any way we don't want
to require that these probabilities be
too high because there are probabilistic
gains that limit the win rate
um for highly skilled players uh as an
example you might have chess with a with
a coin toss at the beginning so both
players toss a coin and the player with
heads wins if there is a difference in
what coin toss but if the coin toss is
the same then they play a game chess
um in this case the win rate would be
kept at 75 but it still might be useful
for a rating system here to model this
uh Plato pool in this game
um and you can imagine playing games
with that that have much lower capped
win rates
so but still we we want the the
rating system to be able to accommodate
an infinite long chain um because that
means that we can't we don't have a
limit to the amount of depth that we you
can model
um formally speaking we call this
probably the this property of infinity
long chains uh full scale and we say
that there it has full scale if there
exists some probability P greater than
0.5 and it infinitely is sending chain
of ratings R1 R2 Etc such that the
probability of R1 being R1 r i feeding r
i minus one is greater than P for all I
um and we our first main result is that
opponent in different rating systems
cannot satisfy full scale
uh to build some intuition on why this
is the case once we have the skill curve
um as separable
in terms of this bisector that's bounded
um
if we have a rating like R2 that has a
advantage of
a probability of beating R1 of P we know
that there is some positive number P
minus 0.5 that's beta of R2 must be
greater than beta of R1 and it's
similarly for R3 for beta lr3 compared
to Beta R2 it must be greater than it by
the same positive number P minus 0.5 and
if you have an infinitely long chain in
ratings
um they have this property eventually
you'll have a beta that it goes beyond
the bounds
um and this will consequently have mean
that you have a skill curve that has
probabilities of winning greater than
one which is impossible
and you might say that we don't need
infinite long skill chains because
um in practice we don't actually get
infinitely long skull chains but even
for very reasonable values of P like
0.75 the maximum skill length of a skill
change is still three for any opponent
in a different rating system which is
which is way too short
um instead of fixing this problem though
we will talk about generalization of
opponent indifference to make future
results a little bit more intuitive
um one thing we assume in opponent
indifference is that our opponents are
correctly rated but in reality they are
most likely to be incorrectly rated we
don't really know most of the time by
how much or or if they're over
underrated but sometimes you you might
know you might have some knowledge about
clear pool so
um if you do have this knowledge it's
National to ask um can we still be
different about opponents that are
miserated by the same amount
and it turns out we can
um we call this property strongly
opponent indifferent and we formally
describe it as having
um the expected gain function depend on
additional parameter Delta where Delta
describes how much your opponent is
misreaded by so instead of assuming that
y um Y and Y star are the same we assume
y star is y plus Delta
and uh we we find additional structure
to strongly opponent in different Range
Systems
um we find that the bisectors must be
linear in fact and these types of rating
systems have two addition um two probes
one is that they generalize the opponent
indifference and two is that having a
linear bisector requires that the
um that the rating system be translation
varies
but it has one big drawback which is
that having a linear bisector within a
bounded range means that the the slope
of the bisection must be zero which then
implies that the scale curve is flat and
must be trivial so these are very
useless but it'll help us build some
intuition about future results
um so moving on to actually fix the
opponent indifference uh we use this
idea of thresholding so you can
threshold where we care and where we are
opponent indifferent and the
thresholding is is used in practice when
implementing a lot of
um
uh rating systems because we assume that
there's some chaos in the game such that
like at the extremes our model doesn't
hold as well
um for example fide which is the um the
official International chess
organization they they bound ELO in
their implementation
um they use something called the 400
Point rule where differences of rating
higher than 400 points are treated the
same as a 400 Point difference
you can see that on the right left here
and our idea is that we only really care
about opponent indifference amongst
ratings that are relative to each other
um this accounts for the common case
um you're not going to be
misrated by that much and you're not
going to be playing people that are
wildly way better than you or widely
worse than you for the most part and we
can we can see that
um later that this bound of what we call
relative is very large so really oh that
that's a and we can still we can still
save opponent difference from being not
able to satisfy full scale with very
large bounds on on this uh what we call
relative so formally speaking we say
that I'm writing X and Y are are
relative if they're P close which means
that the probability of winning is
bounded between 0.5 minus p and 0.5 plus
p and p can be as big as 0.5 itself so
really this means that the probability
of winning is within zero and a hundred
um
so that's a lot
um
and uh we defined Pia opponent
indifference if
essentially opponents are opponent
players are opponent indifferent when
the parameters are equals
um I'm also very very very similar
results as before where we have a
constant K function
um and a separable skill curve but only
when X and Y are P close
and these results imply that there
exists P opponent in different rating
systems that that's why full scale you
can just have a bisector that's
increasing and let's say it's linear for
example you can just bound the skill
curve such that when it's greater than
one
um it just equals one and if it's less
than zero it just equals zero
and that would be a p opponent
indifferent and also satisfy full scale
um and we also can apply the strong
modifier to our notion of P opponent of
difference to get strong P upon the
difference so the definition is very
similar we have strong opponent
difference but only when the parameters
are too close
and we also show similar results
um that the bisector must be linear
which implies translation and variance
for p close values
the more important thing is that these
types of rating systems have shown some
practical utility the sonus rating
system has been argued by Jeff sonus to
be superior to ELO they're predicting
the outcome of high-level chest matches
so in this graph you can see the the
threshold of linear skill curve which
the sonus rating system matches the the
results of
of the of high-level chess matches very
closely so um in conclusion we found
that strong P opponent
um different rating systems reasonably
protecting its opponent in selection
tags and there have had some practical
utility
I'm looking towards the future you see
three ways to expand on this work
um one is to relax our model to include
many systems that are not memoryless not
zero-sum or not one-dimensional and see
if we can satisfy some notion of
opponent difference that way
um we can go into this direction which
was suggested by an anonymous reviewer
where
um you have a separate display rating
that you have full control over and uh
and an actual rating that is used to
rank you and see if you
um if this allows for protection against
opponent selection attacks
and thirdly we have
um we can consider opponent indiffence
along with other desirable properties
maybe like Fast convergence I see in
gluco and other or other natural
um
ideas might be to include other Notions
of strategy groupness
also yeah that's it thank you for
listening uh have a wonderful day